so the bush reagan bush administration
and congress decided that they were
going to deregulate quote unquote
savings and loans and this allowed snl's
to basically invest their money and lend
their money on anything they wanted to
and was an open invitation to the
criminal element and sure enough the
mafia was one of the first people
groups involved in looting snls in the
early 80s and the deregulation that bush
was in charge of
did that
so we went in a sense were financing
these covert illegal operations
and it's the way that of course oliver
north william casey gets away george
bush the way they like to do things now
in texas we found a louisiana monster
named herman k beebe
who was controlling snl's in a different
way than rinda and we found bb and renda
together in many many different places
across the country many connections
between the two this snl that benson
bought after he got out of jefferson
became continental savings and that
purchase was financed by herman k beebe
so it's possible that mafia money went
to lloyd benson
the subject that has been ignored by the
establishment media
pete bruton has written a book about it
and we talk with him right now on
alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today alternative views will interview
pete bruton concerning his book the
mafia cia and george bush pete is a
former houston post reporter who broke
the story of the connections between the
snl scandal and the cia exposing how cia
assets would borrow money from the snls
to finance off the book operations and
then declare bankruptcy and leave u.s
taxpayers with the bill
well for the past five years pete has
been tracking down who actually profited
from the snl scam who the main players
were and how they skimmed off their
money lo and behold pete discovered that
the beneficiaries of the snl scandals
were friends of george bush and his
family unsavory folks connected to the
c.i.a and mafia as well as associates of
texas big shots such as senator lloyd
benson and houston power broker walter
mischer well obviously this is an
explosive story and today we're going to
explore the full ramifications of the
snl crisis with author pete bruton who's
now a law student here at the university
of texas
pete this is such an incredible story
one that is so complex it seems to me
almost one impossible to tell but you do
it so well in your book
before we get into the
intricacies of it i wonder if you can
tell us
how george bush himself was involved in
this his family was
but was he himself involved much bush's
role was on many levels first of all as
vice president during the reagan bush
years he was the head of the reagan bush
deregulation efforts across the board
and that included savings and loans and
the deregulation of savings and loans
that occurred primarily in 1982 with the
saint germain garden bill
basically opened up savings and loans to
the crooks
snl's had traditionally just done home
mortgage lending
to middle class americans and they
succeeded very well for 50 years
they had some problems then in the late
70s and early 80s with the inflation
so the bush reagan bush administration
and congress decided that they were
going to deregulate quote unquote
savings and loans and this allowed snl's
to basically invest their money and lend
their money on anything they wanted to
and was an open invitation to the
criminal element and sure enough the
mafia was one of the first people
groups involved in looting snls in the
early 80s and the deregulation that bush
was in charge of
did that
bush also as vice president
either he or his top aides intervened in
the federal regulation of the biggest
failed savings loan in the country at
that time sunrise savings in boynton
beach florida the ceo of sunrise went
out to bush's office when he was vice
president
and the story varies he tells one story
one time and one story another he either
met with bush with bush's top aides
including c boyd and gray who is the
current white house counsel
and he asked them to get the federal
regulators off his back they were trying
to stop sunrise from basically throwing
their assets away
and
one week after he met with these people
the federal home loan bank board that
regulates savings and loans withdrew a
very stringent cease and desist order
against sunrise and replaced it with a
weak supervisory agreement and a
congressional study found that this move
cost taxpayers possibly 100 million
dollars or more in keeping sunrise open
sunrise was then closed down a year
later year and a half later
at a cost of the federal taxpayers of
700 million dollars
and it was no federal home loan bank
board investigation it was just shut
down
we find if you look at the major
borrowers at sunrise you find mafia
people you find cia people and you find
a houston businessman named john riddle
who he ties into the circle of houston
businessman that george bush comes from
and riddle at this time was involved in
the transshipment of arms to the middle
east
now the top
number two official at the federal home
loan bank board and fairbanks was in
this meeting with the sunrise ceo when
he was asking them to get the fed's
office back
her husband richard fairbanks was in
charge at that time with the state
department's efforts to keep arms from
iran called operation stunts he quit a
year later and became the washington
lawyer and lobbyist for iraq
and worked with iraq until iraq invaded
kuwait
now it's interesting also to note that
the largest failed snl in the country
that did not have a federal home loan
bank board investigation sunrise was
number two largest the largest was hill
financial in red hill pennsylvania that
plays a big part in my book and the
number two borrower at hill financial
was john riddle's buddy
a houston builder named mike atkinson
who at that time was transshipping arms
to the middle east
so you find a connecting thread here of
arms to the middle east and savings and
loans
and bush's office was directly involved
in keeping this sunrise
sunrise state open and was lending money
to john riddle
it seems like
such a complex thing but the same
everywhere you look there are certain
things going on the cia and the mafia
and
there were drugs that were being run
back into the united states there were
illegal arms being
procured and sent to the contras as well
as to iran and iraq as we now know and
iraq
but all of these interests coincided the
mafia
the now how did the mafia with the mafia
just after money is that
and
and perhaps the selling of drugs when
they came back into the united states i
think the mafia just found it as another
you know trough they could feed it and i
think they were in on it at the
beginning when they saw they knew what
deregulation was going to do
and the fact that they they figured out
a scheme and the head of this scheme was
a new york monster named mario rinda
who went to jail for like
less than three years
he was convicted in new york florida and
kansas city
rindah would collect money from various
institutions like pension funds and
credit unions
bundle it up into 100 000 bundle so it's
covered by federal deposit insurance and
then place it in savings loans all
across the country billions of dollars
and once he got the money the deposits
into an snl he could basically control
them he could he had a hammer over their
head if they didn't do with this money
what he wanted to he'd just pull it out
and this was called length financing he
would place the deposits and then tell
the snl's to loan the money to lend the
money to his buddies they would then
just rip it off take it and
rip it off now in texas we found a
louisiana mobster named herman k beebe
who was controlling snl's in a different
way than rinda and we found bibi and
randa together in many many different
places across the country many
connections between the two but bibi
would actually finance the purchase of
savings and loans by his associates like
don dixon and vernon carroll kelly at
continental
jared woods at western
roy daley at first savings of east texas
and then he would have a hammer over
their head where he was holding the note
on their stock to the snl so they would
do what he wanted to
i think it's so significant what you've
pointed out that this isn't just
something the these relationships
weren't something which came together
suddenly when they said oh hey here's a
great big pig let's cut it up
there were this was just a
continuation of relationships between
powerful people
at various levels of state local and
national that have been going on for
some time
that's correct in fact we had a sort of
dry run on the snl scandal in the mid
70s in texas with the so-called texas
rent-a-bank scandal where we have the
same people that showed up in the s l
crisis
ripping off small texas banks and doing
the same thing trading bad loans between
each other
trading capital stock loans between each
other and herman k beebe was in the
middle of that
ben barnes his business partner was in
the middle of it and then later ben
barnes and john conley show up as big
big borrowers at many of the dirtiest
snl's in the country
george alban another guy that was
involved in savings and loans was in the
texas rental bank scandal so and the
federal government knew about the rental
bank scandal they came in and did an
investigation
there was a savings alone in texas in
houston called surety that a woman named
rosemary stewart was in charge of the
federal regulation of in washington and
she saw herman kv she saw walter mischer
she saw mitchell's son-in-law robert
courson and when these people all got
back in the snl's
you know five ten years later she did
nothing
and she was then in charge of the office
of enforcement of the federal home loan
bank board
your book begins in fact by discussing
walter mischer who is a houston banker
and power broker as a major player in
this whole snl scam can you tell a
little bit about him and what role he
actually played in this scenario
yeah walter mischer
was at the very center of the houston
business connections that that all you
take all these snl's you start tracking
back where the money goes and you find
mishra and his friends misher was what
we call a hyphenated texan
banker hyphenated developer
and there's probably a few other hyphens
in there too a political power broker
he controlled politicians on all levels
mishra basically told the houston
developers who they were going to donate
political campaign campaign money to
mischer had the third largest bank in
houston allied bank and he used allied
bank to finance many different things
including some of the dirtiest savings
and loans in houston like continental
savings
mainland savings
and some others
and in fact micheler knew that the snl
were going down the tubes in the early
80s because he sold a savings and loan
he had ben franklin savings
that at one time had belonged to lloyd
benson's company
he also ordered all the
snl capital stock loans out
of allied
in 8283 so that when these snl's failed
he wouldn't be caught holding the bank
and in turn he had many savings and
loans helping he and his bank out
indirectly and one time mainland savings
in houston bought a 20 million dollar
loan that allied held on an oil company
it was in bankruptcy
and a later investigation showed that
mainland lost at least 14 million
dollars on this there was no hope of
repaying and mainland just did it as a
favor to allied the ceo of mainland had
had his mainland stock financed at
allied bank and was a good friend of
walter mischer and what sort of
political friends
did walter mitchell have who are his
main sort of political connections well
mr goes back to the old eight f days the
lamar hotel in houston where the brown
brothers
jesse jones gus wortham these people
were wheeling dealing controlling
houston
and and politicians like lyndon johnson
it goes back that far and then you bring
uh mischer was very close to john conley
ben barnes
lloyd benson and george bush
and most of the houston mayors and
harris county judges
almost all of the texas governors
except for ann richards i'm not sure
about her but we know
dolph briscoe and
even
republicans like bill clements mitchell
was very close to and supported bishop's
political donations and influence went
to both parties it was not just
democrats i mean
he supported democrats of course back in
the 50s and 60s when democrats
controlled this state but he also
you know controlled and helped a lot of
republicans like john tower and
george bush and bill clinton so he was a
well-connected fellow very well
connected and not just of course the
politicians we were connected to the
mafia which was a big shock i mean when
i was reported houston post and people
started telling me about his connections
to the mafia
and
we did a big interview with him and it
was on the cover of the houston post
sunny magazine
and i asked him what about all the
rumors about your connections to carlos
marcelo the new orleans mafia boss and
he admitted that he had sat down to do
business with marcelo at one time
marcelo had come in and wanted to buy
a couple of his hotels including the
carousel hotel on the south loop
and he said he did not sell them to him
because he did not want to get quote run
out of town well it turns out when you
investigate who he really sold it to
turns out to be a marcelo front man and
associate so he really did and misher
and his partners kept the d the title to
this hotel
while marcelo's front man was showing
the x-rated movies and running
prostitutes in this hotel
and what about
h.k bibi
his connections with walter michener and
the mob yeah well bibi the royal
louisiana mafia associate from
shreveport
had turned up first in the texas
rent-a-bank scandal where he was
connected to ben barnes who of course
was in walter mitchell's hip pocket
bibi then
was borrowing money from mr's allied
bank mission was supporting him making
him
operating loans
giving him insurance business and in one
case
the stock of continental savings in
houston
was financed at missions allied bank
with a guarantee from herman k beebe
so they were very close in doing
business not only in the tex houston
area but in louisiana we find associates
of measure very close associates
including the former controller of the
currency robert clark
going in and buying a bank with herman k
beebe in louisiana along with two the
two top executives at missions bank
now was he was bibi uh under marcelo
well absolutely
and this had been determined
actually by the texas attorney general's
organized crime strike force in the mid
70s john hill has actually had
an organized crime investigative unit
headed by i believe tim james
and they found the connections between
herman k beebe
and carlos marcello
bibi was also tied to marcelo by the new
orleans metropolitan crime commission
this is back in the mid 70s and then you
find all of the connections then
later with the snl scandal
can you give us an example of how the
mafia comes in with the mob
loots a savings alone or two and then
move on well they would
in bibi's case he would actually finance
the the controlling stock of an snl and
then the loans would be made to either
bb or his associates and then they would
take the money and walk the loans
and
leaving the snl with property that
wasn't worth anyone or what they'd lent
on it and that's the way they'd
basically fail how did the cia get
involved in with these people well
that's a good question i i don't think
we know the final answer yet
there are some people who believe that
william casey
had been in on the beginning of the
deregulation and knew that it was
susceptible you know casey was an old
wall street lawyer and head of the sec
at one time
and knew that the the snl's were very
vulnerable to being looted and the money
taken out and and never found
but on the other hand we have people
like walter mischer
who are connected to the cia can
probably see
that if they keep the cia happy you know
dirting some of the money to cia
operations
then you know they will get what the fbi
calls the cia's get out of jail free
card
in other words if they're working doing
and helping the cia and they get caught
and the cia can come in and say
don't prosecute this person
he's working with us and that happened
on a number of occasions in the snl
crisis
where we would have a
savings and loan looter
or a bank loader getting caught by the
fbi and the justice department the cia
trying to get them off the hook because
they work with them now we've had on
alternative views those of you been
watching alternative years regularly
know that about the drug scams which
were going on where illegal arms would
be shipped down to the contraries
particularly and the c-130s would be
filled up with
cocaine and all and brought back in the
united states and offloaded sometimes at
u.s
air force bases sometimes at
more covert landing strips
now
how would this operation fit in with
what we're talking about right
we found a number of people in florida
that were helping the contrast taking
weapons guns for drugs that were
involved in fail banks and savings and
loans
one
cia
gun and drug runner was a guy named jack
devoe
and devoe was actually bringing in his
cocaine into the ocean reef club on key
largo it was owned by carl linder the
cincinnati
businessman
and he's very close to bush very close
to bush okay bush would go down and
actually vacation at the ocean reef club
there's a picture in my book
a bush and a fishing boat off ocean reef
and this is where jack devoe was
bringing in his cocaine and devoe was
also taking guns down to latin america
for the cia
now devos money launderer was a miami
attorney named lawrence freeman freeman
had previously worked for paul hellewell
one of the founding fathers of the c.i.a
and also was laundering money for santo
trafficante the tampa florida
mafia boss
freeman drew up the documents the sales
contract for a 21 000 acre land deal on
the florida panhandle that hill
financial savings the one in
pennsylvania we previously talked about
envision bank savings in kingsville
texas that was owned by walter mischer's
former son-in-law
financed here we have lawrence freeman
drawing up the papers and involved with
these people and he's you know closely
connected the cia had been the in-house
counsel for castle bank and trust in
nassau
a bank that was used by the mafia and
the cia to hide and launder money and
was shut down when paul hellowell died
and it appeared that many of these
these offshore money laundering
operations were moved after castlebank
failed and was shut down to the isle of
jersey and lawrence freeman was
laundering jack duveau's drug money
through the isle of jersey uh robert
corson mishra's former son-in-law and
mike atkinson were laundering snl money
through the isle of jersey along with
some people in colorado that connect to
neil bush
all were using the same the same trust
the same trust on the isle of jersey
were getting drug money and snl money
and they were mixed in in the same bank
accounts
um pete could you give us some examples
of how the cia would loot snls and what
they'd use the money for well it's not
like the cia would you get a loan from
an snl and down the bottom line you know
for guns guns to the conference signed
by the cia right
that's not the way they operate i mean
they use cutouts and front people so
that to maintain their plausible
deniability so they can come in and deny
that it wasn't them and what's a cut out
then a cutout is a front man a middle
person who may not even know he's
working for the cia
i think there could be four or five
levels
of cutouts and front men the layers that
the cia would the money would flow
through
so that it couldn't be tracked back to
the cia
one of the best examples we have in the
snl's was with mainland savings
this is the snl that walter misher was
financing the stock of this is the esmel
who's who's chairman of the board
raymond hill was a close and long time
friend of james a baker iii
white house chief of staff former
treasury secretary former secretary of
state george bush's best friend
when mainland failed
james baker's old law firm andrews and
kurth in houston was brought in by the
feds to investigate the failure and file
a lawsuit against the officers and
directors to try to recover the lost
money
andrews and kurth investigated
actually drew up a lawsuit a petition
but was never found it was stopped at
the top layers of andrews kurt and the
federal government and as a result no
lawsuit was ever filed against raymond
hill the the mainland ceo and no money
was ever recovered
no indictments have ever been filed
against anybody in the failure of
mainland savings
okay so here we have this snl it's wired
in to walter mischer and james baker
in the summer of 1985 james baker went
before a senate finance committee as
treasury secretary
and told them that there was nothing to
worry about in the snl's everything was
wonderful and fine and nothing bad was
going to happen
at the very same time
mainland savings was entering into a 68
million dollar land deal with adnan
khashoggi
a saudi arabian middleman
an arms dealer
and
it was a very complicated deal the
result of it was that khashoggi walked
away with about 16 million dollars in
cash profit pure profit from this land
deal
the taxpayers later got stuck with about
a 50 million dollar loss on this deal
this was close this deal was closed and
the money transferred on august the 1st
1985.
six days later adnan khashoggi begins
the transfer of five million dollars to
gobarifar the iranian middlemen to start
the first publicized arms for hostages
deal it's interesting that he
transferred five million dollars to
garbonifar because at the same time
mainland was basically giving him 16
million dollars they also gave him a 5
million dollar letter of credit that was
very strange because it could only be
drawn on the first week in november of
85.
and had all the earmarks of a guarantee
and in fact later when khashoggi's
people were trying to cover this up from
the fbi who caught on to this pretty
soon
they said it was a to guarantee
some stock that khashoggi had bought
from mainland but the money to buy that
stock had come from mainland steel in
other words mainland gave khashoggi 10
million dollars he gives it back to them
in exchange for 10 million dollars in
stock and they said oh by the way here's
a letter of credit
for five million dollars to guarantee
this stock it didn't make any sense at
all because it came from mainland
the money came from mainland but the
five million dollars matches exactly the
five million dollars that khashoggi paid
kobani for so pete this is in a sense
the beginning of iran contra that's
funded with snl money so one of the
reasons why baker and bush and the u.s
government was not
regulating the snl's was not doing
something about this crisis that was
emerging is because they were using the
snls to finance some of their off the
book activities they didn't want
congress or the public to look into i
think is that a correct i think that's
ultimately what happened now whether we
can prove that they quote use them
you know we'll probably never know but
that is the ultimate upshot of what
happened and the money of course from
mainland ultimately came from the
american taxpayers so we went in a sense
were financing
these covert illegal operations
and it's the way that of course oliver
north william casey has awaited george
bush the way they like to do things i
mean
north testified before congress that
what william casey was looking for and
trying to set up was a self-sustaining
off-the-shelf
self-financing covert operation and here
we had it
we see it in operation with the savings
on money that ultimately came from the
american taxpayer so you know khashoggi
wasn't out any money
the iranians and israelis really weren't
out anybody came from the american
taxpayers incredible now in the so much
of what we've talked about previously in
alternative views and in a lot of the
news stories that you would read
they would mainly focus on the savings
and loans themselves and all these
wheelers and dealers like don dixon up
in vernon savings or charles keating and
all of that but we're talking about a
stratum above
that those people aren't we oh
definitely i think dixon and keating and
all the others ed mcburney and jared
woods tyrell barker were just front men
i mean they were cutouts basically and
if you look at how much money they got i
call them one or two percenters
dixon got maybe what 20 million dollars
out of vernon i mean he himself and
vernon is costing taxpayers over 1
billion dollars
keating got about 40 million dollars
and lincoln savings is costing taxpayers
2 billion dollars so you can see you're
getting one or two percent
and and it's a classic front man setup
and uh the people that you have to who's
really getting this money and you start
scratching and digging you find that
you're in another stratum as you say of
businessmen who are connected to the
politicians very strongly of course
keating had strong connections too but
if you look at who got the money out of
out of lincoln you find
john conley and ben barnes getting close
to 100 million dollars
uh you find a little bank in paris
called saudi european paris texas paris
oh no actually paris france there's
france yeah
it connects into the bcci oh i see and
keating was investing money in in that
and you start scratching and digging you
find
even bigger players than keating behind
this so then there's that this layers
the layer of the mafia and the cia
and was anybody was there another layer
above them like the big banks they must
they were getting the money
the benefits of the
money laundering from drugs because they
would be laundered through the
u.s big banking system well that's
correct were they also benefiting from
this at a even
same level or higher level well the
banks and insurance companies believe it
or not where some of the big
institutions got bailed out by the snls
if you had a piece of property or an
office building that the first mortgage
or the first lien on it might be held by
a big bank or big insurance company and
when the savings and loan would come in
and take out
everything and refinance the whole deal
the banks and snl would get paid off by
the savings amount in fact that happened
in the khashoggi deal
texas commerce bank had a 15 million
dollar a mortgage against khashoggi's
property
and the money to pay off that mortgage
came from mainland savings and also
lamar savings in austin
joined in in that so texas commerce bank
got all their money back from the
savings and loans you find it happened
time and time again
a piece of property will have a first
big first mortgage by a bank or
insurance company that will get paid off
by the s l when they take the whole deal
out well as i understand the big banks i
mean the wall street banks and all
a lot of these deals a lot of the
property would be resold and eventually
they would come up into the hands of
these bigger banks and insurance
companies like in new york and so i
guess they would be the first ones to be
paid off in any type of bailout would
they not well sure i mean if they're
holding the first mortgage they get
they're going to get the money first
before anybody the savings loan might be
holding a third or fourth mortgage i
mean they would wrap these things and
flip these things
so that the snl might be third or fourth
in line and would never get once the
property sold
in the first mortgage
mortgage e is paid off
the snl's left with nothing
pete there's a chapter in your book
called the mobsters spooks and george
bush the palmer national bank story that
ties all these things that we're talking
about together in other words the way
that high level officials with
connections to the government corporate
and political officials
formed a bank the palmer national bank
and how it became connected with all
these unsavory operations you want to
give us some detail on this to sort of
concretely illustrate this analysis the
palmer national bank had just about
everybody in it it was a small bank
still exists in washington dc about two
blocks north of the white house
i was started by a louisiana businessman
named harvey maclean
and a political operative from
washington d.c called stephen halper and
maclean and halper met in 1980 when they
were both working on george bush's
presidential campaign
and halper later was was head of the
policy
group for bush and then when reagan
became the nominee and bush was named
vice pres vice presidential candidate
halper went to work for their campaign
as part of the policy group and was
actually
a high level official in what they call
the october surprise group
the group that was trying to determine
whether or not carter was going to pull
off an october surprise and get the
iranian hostages home or whatever might
and halper was was in charge of this
group his father-in-law was ray klein
who was the former deputy director of
intelligence of the cia klein was
working with them with bush and then
when reagan and bush won
halper went to work for the state
department they created a position for
him and james baker by the way was the
one that brought halper over to the
reagan bush
team after reagan became the nominee
from from the bush team
so and harvey mclean was a businessman
from shreveport louisiana
and he was being financed by none other
than herman k beebe the mafia associate
maclean
moves to dallas and buys paris savings
alone in paris texas and is borrowing
money from vernon savings from
continental savings in houston
and later of course all these loans go
bad and paris goes bust and mclean's
business deals cost taxpayers probably
over 100 million dollars
that's kind of getting ahead of the
story back in 83
mclean and halper taking a trip to china
and they start talking about let's get a
bank in washington dc and so they they
start palmer national bank palmer was
named after mclean's grandmother and
daughter
and the capital the three million
dollars capital to start the bank came
from herman k beebe and bozier a bank
and trusted the guy connected to the mob
in louisiana
he seems to be over he's everywhere
and the measure and ben barnes john
connolly
all these people
so when soon they start this bank they
begin lending money to conservative
republican pacs like bob dole
and jack kemp
and then they take on another client the
national endowment for the preservation
of liberty
which was started by oliver north and a
guy named spitz channel
to funnel private donations to the
contras
okay and of course the biggest owner was
ellen garwood
uh here in austin the widow of the
former supreme court justice
um
and
palmer nationwide was also lending money
to the national endowment
for operating loans and for furniture
loans and helping funnel the money
that's where they had the bank would the
money would go from palmer national bank
to
another
washington bank to the cayman islands
and then over to geneva switzerland
um in in the bank account
uh at credit suisse where um
not only was contra money being flowed
into but iranian honors prophets were
awesome
that was that was c chords and then then
it would go out to the contrast
and palmer was that was the starting
point of the money
and uh palmer national bank also made a
loan
on a a beach house in solano beach
california that bb and dixon
would use to entertain
snl regulators
including l.l bowman
in fact that's where he allegedly
had a tryst with a prostitute
in that beach house
and palmer national bank had a piece of
the action on that
beach house
and
later stefan halper was when he got
caught in a debate gate scandal if you
call that the
the theft of the carter debating uh
manuals that ended up in the reagan bush
campaign that apparently james baker or
william casey or both of them were
involved in and that was just part of an
enormous covert action against the
carter administration which they had
something like 137 operatives at all
kinds of high levels
spying snooping and even stealing top
secret documents and this is just one of
their uh will help parents that's
correct well halper was involved in that
and of course his name surfaced in 1984
when this came out and he had to sort of
leave he kind of backed out of palmer
national bank
but he stayed in touch with these people
of course and then when oliver north
was fired by reagan in november 1986
when the
when the scheme where they were you know
using profits from the iranian uh
arms deals to fund the contras and all
came tumbling out and reagan fired north
the very last entry in oliver north's
white house diaries was legal defense
firm
dash stephen halper
our old palmer national bank guy who
also again i want to make this october
surprise connection because halper was
the head of the october surprise
committee for the reagan election team
in 1980 which was frightened to death
that the carter administration was going
to negotiate
the release of the hostages which may be
one of the reasons why they stole the
debate book as well as did these other
covert actions against carter because
they wanted to find out what he was
doing for this hostage release and if
possible subvert it and give the
iranians a better deal at least that's
the account that gary sick and others
give that's correct
and how it worked out that way they
rigged a deal so that
the iranians would hold the hostages
until after the election and return for
arms and lo and behold 20 minutes after
reagan raised his hand and said that he
would ruin the country the
hostages were released well
and here we have this little bank you
know that was involved in all this being
financed with louisiana mafia money and
when herman cavey was convicted first
convicted in 1985 of course they moved
that loan out of bozier bank to a little
savings and loan in beaumont texas
called san jacinto savings different
from san jacinto and houston and if you
look at
the board members of that bank you find
two people who were
major stockholders in the casinos
caesars
casino in las vegas that of course was
was being
skimmed by the chicago mafia at that
time so it's absolutely incredible how
all this is connected october surprise
iran contra snl
mafia cia all of william casey all of
these operations under the reagan
administration were interconnected as
well as the players
that you find the same people in the
same threads running through
these these operations and the money you
know from snl is going into these
operations can you tell us another story
about a landing strip in lajitas texas
yes
i first found out about the possible
connections to the savings and loans and
the cia
and i guess the fall of 1988 when a
woman in houston called up
my associate the houston post greg c
and told him berated him about some of
our coverage of snl that weren't getting
the whole story so we went to see her
her name was rebecca sims she had been
robert courson
mitchell's former son-in-law
his account
and she had quit because she'd been
asked to commit bankruptcy and tax fraud
and so she started investigating courson
and she found out that courson had been
a asset of the cia
and
when she first told me that
i
really wasn't interested in it at all
i had no interest in it i wasn't looking
for the sea i was looking at the mafia
and i guess i was even a little
disappointed but when i went back to my
office i remembered several things one
when we had done the story on walter
mission and been calling everybody
all his people he knew just get
background information on him
one of his close associates told me
about the 700 000 acres in belize in
central america he's bought into
and that his associate thought that this
was a cia operation
and this was someone who's very close to
measure and
would not say something like that unless
he knew it would have something to and
i'd sort of follow that you know way in
my mind i remember that came up and then
i remember there was a organized crime
strike force prosecutor in kansas city
that was chasing mario rinda
the new york mob money broker
and i had been i was chasing randa too
so we had a lot of contact i've been
sending him our stories we've been
writing in the houston post
and he said almost the same thing
rebecca sims had said you're missing
something big here or something you're
not getting and so i wondered if he was
talking about the cia so i
flew out to kansas city and and met with
him and sure enough that was it
he was talking about the cia so that's
how the cia connection arose and and
rebecca sims had been told
about the cia connection from a man
named richard breneke
oh my gosh
his name pops up
drugs drugs
he had been the sort of renegade
intelligence agent
in portland oregon uh he had
received a lot of no right notoriety
because he had
some of the breaking stories on iran
country had come from him
on the iranian arms deals and some of
the contra arms deals and the new york
times newsweek had used him as a major
source
and so
i went up to see breneke and i i spent a
week with him
and when i when i got back i really
didn't have much because brennecke
didn't have a lot of documents backing
up what he was saying it was a very
frustrating experience with bernice he's
a typical
kind of intelligence agent that will
will deliberately lie to you on some
occasions i mean you just can't trust
everything he tells you but on the other
hand he will tell you the truth on a
number of cases
and he at one point in our conversations
began describing a landing strip in far
west texas
that had been a cia guns for drugs deal
uh you know guns and drugs transshipment
point and he said they flew c130s and uh
there is a four thousand so i i ripped a
big sheet of paper out of my legal
notebook and i said draw me a map
you know so he starts drawing this map
and here was lahitas which is west of
big bend easy you go he said about 10
miles northeast and there's this mesa
and he had a very detailed map
four thousand he gave me the the the way
it was oriented uh the fact that there
was a mountain just north of it and
there was a mesa there and so i took
that back to houston
with me um
hoping you know i didn't maybe this
would check out
so i got a
usgs class a topo map of the area which
i was absolutely positive would show a
landing strip that big four thousand
feet
and i get the map out and i look at it
and i can see about where it should have
been according to his his map and there
was nothing on the map
and so i said well i'll give it one more
shot
i'll get the aerial photographs that
they use to make these maps they take
aerial photographs
and so on the area of photographs and i
got them out and i looked at them and
there it was right exactly where the
landing strip exactly where he described
it and the faa had no record of this it
wasn't on any map
and so i went out out to that to it's
about 15 miles northeast of lajitas
and about oh i'd say less than 10 miles
from terlingua
and actually drove out to it and looked
at it and began talking to people about
it and basically got it confirmed that
it was a
c-130s flew in there with arms and drugs
and uh
and breneke had told me
that when he flew in there
that he asked the people he was flying
in there with who were people
by the way associated with the medellin
cartel
whose landing strip this was he was told
it was what they told him walter mischer
now mr owns
at that time it owned probably
close to 300 000 maybe more acres in
that area but he didn't own that piece
of property he had land to the west of
it and land to the south of it so when i
began researching who owned this
property i found a widow
in florida
actually owned that property and she had
never been there
in her life
and only found out a few years before i
talked to her that a landing strip was
there because one of her relatives went
hunting and told her did you know
there's a landing strip right in the
middle of your property
and she said no
and she said it was done without her
knowledge or permission
and of course what a great it was
actually the only place
in that area that's a very rough rugged
country there
just west of big bend it was the only
level place for miles and miles around
in that vicinity that you could put a
landing strip and of course if a widow
from florida has never been there owns
it
and just about anybody wanted to
probably could
of course the law enforcement had to
know about it when you talk to them
you get contradictory answers and
inconsistent answers and they're trying
to cover up obviously
although they would acknowledge that
they've seen c-130s in the vicinity
there's no reason for c1 of course there
is a low-level training route for c-130s
out of san antonio
in that area what what a perfect cover
of course for flying in c-130s
can we get up to a higher level of
politics again
mr clean mr benson lloyd benson he's
connected with this in some way yeah i
went into benson in a number of places
the first place i ran into lloyd benson
was in jefferson savings which was in
the rio grande valley i believe in
mcallen
jefferson savings had been started by
lloyd benson and his brother and
benson's father
back in the mid 50s and they controlled
it up until the mid 70s
when they sold it to a man named
guillermo hernandez cartage
cartage is one of one of the really bad
boys of the western hemisphere
he's a cuban exile fought in the bay of
pigs was a member of the infamous
2506
had been involved in
narcotics trafficking money laundering
gun running terrorist activities out of
florida with a company called world
finance
the irs the fbi had close to 200 people
investigating world finance in the mid
70s and
alt was ready to pop cartelia big when
the cia
stopped them and came in and basically
had the the investigation dismantled
and
as a result cartalya was just convicted
on income tax charges
at that very same time
he comes and buys jefferson savings from
the benson family
okay and proceeds to loot it and run
drug money through it
when the justice department came in to
investigate cartelia
we're brought in by the texas regulators
and art lizard who was the chief snl
examiner for the state of texas brought
in the feds
the cia came down and met with the
prosecutor and asked him to back off
cartelia because of all the favors
cortalia had done for our government
including it turns out scamming about 30
million dollars from a
united arab emirates bank
with the apparent permission of the cia
and cartila the act the justice
department did not
back off cartage on that deal he was
convicted but his sentence was rolled
into his irs sentence
and i don't know how many years he
probably only did a couple of years in
jail
the next year after that happened
cartelia was again indicted along with
his partner camilo padre another cuban
exile in miami
that indictment was stopped for some
reason
the justice department said later it was
flawed but if it's flawed why don't they
draw it up
camilo padre shows up
10 years later as a partner of jeb bush
the president's son in miami
now
when i found out about cortalia and also
jefferson saves the fact that lloyd
benson
had you know owned part of that
i called up benson's office
i asked him about it
i got his press secretary jack devore
i asked him my questions you know what
was benson's role in this snl you know
what he owned did he know cartage et
cetera et cetera
and divorce had to get back to me that
the senator was in some conference on
the canary islands which is off the
coast of africa
about an hour later dvorak calls me back
and said the senator never owned any
stock in this snl doesn't know anything
about never had anything to do with it
i said are you sure about this he said
yes i satisfied myself he doesn't recall
owning anything
and i said well that's funny i got a
document here from the snl
department that shows he owned 16.7
percent of the original stock and
continued to own it up into the 60s and
these these signatures are notarized
he said i'll get back to you
[Laughter]
30 minutes later i get a call from lloyd
benson himself from the canary islands
saying oh yes he had owned stock in that
but he got out of it in the mid season
and bought in brazosport savings which
later became continental savings
okay
and then i asked him about cartilage i
said what about the cia interference he
assured me that hadn't happened because
he would have known about it well in
fact i got this story straight from the
prosecutor that the cia went to
and so either benson lied to devore or
devore lied to me there's no other
explanation for it i mean they somebody
lied i mean they told me a lie that
benson had never been only stock in this
snl and if i hadn't had that document
they would have gotten away with a lie
now uh it's interesting to note that
this snl that benson bought after he got
out of jefferson
became continental savings and that
purchase was financed by herman k beebe
so it's possible that mafia money went
to lloyd benson now when i asked davor
about that
he said they didn't know that bb was
financing kelly and so it had no
knowledge carol kelly got on that
whether my this was my money or not but
in fact it was well didn't benson also
later in when he was running as vice
president and he put the gabasha on any
investigation or statements and any of
the debates about the snl's isn't that
part of your book too yes well you know
in 1988
the country knew we had an snl problem
we didn't know the extent of it okay the
the original estimates had been
something like maybe 10 15 million
dollars
the republicans of course was bush as
the candidate did not bring up the s you
know being bush's son neal was right in
the middle of silverado savings
which was about to be taken down in fact
was taken down only a couple of weeks
after the presidential election someone
in washington had called the regulators
in topeka kansas that regulated
silverado and told them not to shut
silverado down
until after the presidential election
and that's in fact what happened on the
other side benson was the democratic
vice presidential nominee he went to the
dukakis campaign people and told them
not to bring up the snl crisis and so
they did the democrats did not use that
as an issue and they could have pounded
the republicans over the head with it
or maybe won the election and that's 880
perhaps and of course we had you know we
had the keating five
for the keating five were democrats
i mean the democratic congress had just
as much to answer for as a republican
administration and so neither side
wanted to bring it up of course both
sides were being paid off but by people
like mishra i mean they always cover
their bets these the people like measure
you know they support both sides so
regardless of who wins they've got an
end and george bush and lloyd benson are
part
and parcel of this same small houston
businessman circle
that walter mischer is at the middle of
joe russo is part of
and a guy named jim bath
a cia operative in houston uh is good
friends with george bush and george
bush's son
george w bush and and has done
investments for lloyd benson and was in
business with lloyd benson's son
and bath of course ties in with mischer
mystery got loans from mrs bank
and it's all a very tight little circle
here
that that the bush and benson are
are two peas in a pod
as far as being controlled and dealing
with and have friendship with the same
people
and what about any other connections
that benson might have to the snl crisis
other than him owning this one snl for
20 years did he have investments in or
connections with other snl's who were
involved in the crisis or did he do
things as a senator that might
be involved in
making sure there's no investigations
etc well i don't know if he'd ever
directly intervened but he certainly
didn't push for it and he was head of
the senate finance committee that could
have done all sorts of investigations he
never did i mean in fact he did his best
to see that the snl crisis was not
brought up
he had three savings and loans at one
time it all ended up in the hands of
either the mafia or the cia people
jefferson savings went to cartila
continental savings went to carroll
kelly was financed completely by herman
k beebe and ben franklin say these later
ended up in the hands of walter mescher
now this in and of itself is absolutely
incredible that snl's or banks or any
institution can be sold to mafia
controlled groups how is this even
possible well it's possible because
the people in power either don't know or
don't want to know that these are mafia
people i mean we you know the justice
department had not done the kind of
investigation required the federal
homeland bank board wasn't doing
investigations
and the press was not reporting of
course everybody knew who beede was from
the dallas morning news wrote about the
bb and the texas rental bank scandal but
seem to forget about it
you know ten years later when they're
back involved in snls and no one you
know raised up i mean we've got congress
not doing anything we've got the justice
department not doing anything we got the
press
not doing anything
but the public is not going to find out
and nobody's going to know
and what did benson say that he didn't
know that these were mafia connections
that he just sold his
interests and someone bought them and he
didn't investigate well i think he knew
who he was selling to but he he could
say we didn't know the money was coming
from the mafia well
that's you know that's the kind of
ignorance we don't need if it indeed he
didn't know i mean it's an ignorance
that's almost criminal
i mean if it's not if it's not he didn't
do anything criminal by actually knowing
and intending to happen his ignorance
borders on recklessness
pete we have a lot more questions for
you and we're out of time for this
program but would you like to continue
on and do a second program we want to
get into how you got this story and the
incredible information that you got and
then wove together and the problems you
had in getting stories printed and also
getting the book published
we would would you stay here and do us
the favor of that sure great thank you
that's the end of this alternative views
frequently hear from viewers who request
a list of news publications which we use
on alternative views and also a reading
list for u.s power structure in the mass
media
if you would like to have these send a
stamped self-addressed envelope
to the alternative information network
po box 7279
austin texas 787-13
you must send a self-addressed stamped
envelope
i'd like to thank our crew for making
our program possible brian lynch was our
director assisted by ashley blake mary
mcdonald carrie mcparland and dina
craven
alternative views is a presentation of
the alternative information network
po box 7279
austin texas
787 13.
goodbye
then you start saying something big is
going on here and you start pushing i
mean if we hadn't run into the
roadblocks we might have stopped with
that first story but when you start
running it everywhere people covering up
the government not doing anything nobody
seeming to care where these billions of
dollars went are cared to try to get
them back
that's when you start looking for you
know you know you've got a big story
and i i told the editor who was alice
mayhew
who was bob woodward's editor a very
famous editor
you know that the book needed to go
before the election we needed to get
going and she said she wasn't going to
do that we're not going to do the book
before the election
and i said why not you know all this
stuff about bush the american public
needs to know
and she said quote george bush is going
to win anyway
his writings on the mob
the cia and george bush have been
ignored by the irregular media
and the congress
subjected to censorship
in houston
but now pete brewton talks freely on
alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the second part of our
alternative views interview with author
pete brewton peter's just public
published a book called the mafia cia
and george bush and on our last program
we told how pete analyzed the connection
between the c.i.a and the snl fraud and
how he discovered that george bush and
his family unsavory folks connected to
the c.i.a and the mafia as well as
associates of texas big shots such as
senator lloyd benson and houston power
broker walter mischer were all involved
in the snl fraud which was one of the
greatest u.s financial catastrophes and
crimes in our history today however
we're going to talk about how pete came
to break this story about his
experiences as a houston post reporter
in which he discovered the connections
between the snl and the cia scandal how
he decided to write a book his
experiences with simon and schuster and
how he finally got his book published
and what the response of the book by the
media has been
you've been tracking this snl thing for
a long time what is the magnitude
of the scandal
well we we all hear about is going to
cost
taxpayers about 500 billion dollars
that includes a little over 200 billion
of actual losses that the snls have
incurred that fail that the taxpayers
are going to have to pay back but when
you
throw in interest and carrying costs you
get over 500 billion dollars in direct
costs but the other costs are almost as
bad what these fraudulent snls did was
create an artificial real estate bubble
where they inflated real estate values
artificially
very much and then the bubble burst
and that sort of spread out
that the fallout from that spread to the
banks and insurance companies and any
other financial institutions that were
lending on on real estate
and so one of the reasons the banks are
in big trouble now is their real estate
portfolio and the the larger rate a such
a portfolio bank has the more trouble
it's in
so
that the effects spread out through the
economy in in the real estate value so
it's not just 500 billion which is an
incredible hit but also the indirect
real estate effects i guess also you
could crank into this the amount of
money that was skimmed and stolen by all
these people was money which did not go
into productive resources
so that we're losing out from that
aspect also absolutely i mean when you
think about
somebody has estimated that the actual
cost
when when we start paying it back to
taxpayers going to be 25 billion dollars
a year
from now on forever you think about what
25 billion dollars every year what we
could have used for that and then when
you think about the money was basically
looted and stolen
and that congress and justice department
are not trying to get it back and that's
one of the keys to all this is tracing
the money and also trying to recover it
there's been none of that i mean
congress doesn't want to do it because
they're involved up to their eyeballs
when you start tracing this money like
you did with the keating five you find
it comes in someone comes back to their
own campaign
you know chess
and the justice department which is
controlled by the the president
of course has not tried to track the
money they're interested in just
getting
the front men and the cutouts and the
middlemen to cop guilty pleas
and go to jail maybe for a year or two
and then go on to the next one so they
rack up all these convictions but they
don't try to really figure out what
happened and where the money went and
who benefited pete one of the reasons
why the government has not done any real
prosecution or investigation of this
scandal is because they've been involved
in it going all the way to the top up to
george bush we didn't really get into
last time the complicity of george
bush's son neil in a snl scandal the
silverado case perhaps we can go into
that as an illustration of how the snl
scandal worked and the complicity of top
establishment officials in this crisis
sure
we all know that neil was a director of
silverado savings in denver colorado and
that when he was on the board of
directors he was being supported
financially by a couple of denver
businessmen named ken good and bill
walters at the same time walters and
goode were borrowing huge amounts of
money from silverado and in fact neil
got his hands slapped in administrative
action for approving loans to his
business associate bill walters
what we don't know what hasn't come out
really before
are the connections between not only
good at walters
but to other silverado borrowers to
mafia people and to the cia
and we find that if you look at bill
walters bill walters was the largest
borrower at silverado savings
he signed on about 130 million dollars
of loans in addition
he sold property to silverado about 90
million dollars
walters was a denver architect
walters and his partners including a guy
named richard ross miller were involved
in the texas winterbank scandal back in
the mid 70s with herman k beebe
i mean bb was in ben barnes were
involved in deals with these people and
bibi specifically
had transferred about a million dollars
to richard rossman or bill bill walter's
partner and they had all owned a bank in
marshall texas that was involved in the
texas winter bank scandal
and we found that walters was also
apparently and had been accused of
transferring some of his ill-gotten
gains to a trust in the isle of jersey
that was being
funneled drug money was being laundered
through it by
people in miami and snl money
from people like robert course and the
cia agent was going also going through
this trust fund
ken good
who borrowed over 40 million dollars
from silverado and was neil bush's sugar
daddy for several years
had also borrowed money from western
savings in dallas that was part of the
hermann kbb
circle
the biggest company that actually dealt
with silverado was mdc holdings it was
whose chief executive is larry mizell
mizell was a big republican donor
he held fundraisers that george bush
went to
and mizell
had established trust funds
by done by a chicago law firm
whose partner was burton cantor
burton cantor was one of the founding
fathers of castle bank and trust
the bank in the bahamas at the mafia and
the cia were using
he was involved with cia projects mafia
projects in california
and other mafia figures
and here we have his trust you know
larry mizell's trust fund being set up
by burton cantor's law firm and burton
cantor was also a close associate of
lawrence freeman the miami lawyer
who had worked for paul hellewell the
cia founding father and worked for the
mafia and had been involved in the big
florida land deal
that uh robert corson's snl was funding
so we find this circle you start pulling
on this thread you look at the people
involved in silverado and you're back
with the mafia the cia
now how did neil bush get involved in
all of this what was his initial
connection with silverado what did he
get out of it neil bush
had gone to denver after getting out of
college and was a land man for amaco i
believe which mean he went and tried to
secure leases so they could drill on the
land
and then
bill walters
and ken good set him up in his own
company okay they were both big
republican donors ken good went to the
inauguration party with neil bush in
houston in 1988 when bush won uh bush
visited
bill walters home
in the 1984 campaign bill walters tore
up all his brown grass and laid new
green grass on his lawn just for george
bush's visit because they were pumping
money into neil bush's company that was
drilling dry holes in wyoming was not
making any money he was being basically
a salary of being paid by these people
and his company got a big line of credit
at bill walters bank so they were
supporting him ken good put him on the
board of directors of a florida company
he had and was paying him over a hundred
thousand dollars a year in director's
fees i mean outrageous uh 12 million i
mean 12 000 a month
was going uh to neil bush
for just serving on ken good's board
they were basically keeping him going uh
and he had protection money it sounds
like well you know it's almost somebody
made the analogy that neil bush was sort
of like the driver of the getaway car
and you know the cops weren't going to
shoot at the president's son
and so far all we've had is one
indictment the the ceo michael wise is
the only indictment so far on silverado
savings now what about neil bush and
silverado what role did he play well he
was in particular director and he
approved loans
to his buddy bill walters he also
approved loans
to the second largest borrower at
silverado was a houston con man named e
trine starnes
stars borrowed 77.5 million dollars from
silverado six months after he donated
thirty thousand dollars to the contrast
and went and had a meeting with ronald
reagan and oliver north
and he also borrowed over 25 million
dollars from continental savings in
houston that was supported by mafia
money from herman k beebe
and starnes was also involved with john
riddle the guy who was transshipping
arms to the middle east
and had had gotten support from
allied bank walter mishra's bank
and he turns out to be the second
largest borrower at silverado savings
so neil bush was was basically just
sitting on the board almost like a
figurehead but approving these loans
and uh you know helping his buddies out
and getting paid also for it as a
director that's correct although not
nearly as much as he got from from being
a director on ken good's company
let's talk about how you got this
incredible story now your book
is to me a masterpiece in the sense that
everything is so complex
there's so many interconnections and so
many layers of activity and yet you were
able to lay it out
so that it it makes sense and you can
follow it
my first question is how did you get all
this voluminous material and keep track
of it well i've been working on for over
five years i mean anybody can
probably collect that much information
in five years you know
i've got three four drug file cabinets
full of documents that
support all this information but i mean
you just take one step at a time and
when i first started on the snl story in
the spring of 87
and looking at one deal at mainland
savings in houston
when it failed in 86 was the largest
failure in the country
and you start running into roadblocks
and people not talking you can't get
documents and nobody's being prosecuted
the money isn't being tracked and
nobody's trying to get the money back
then you start saying something big is
going on here and you start pushing i
mean if we hadn't run into the
roadblocks we might have stopped with
that first story but when you start
running it everywhere people covering up
the government not doing anything nobody
seeming to care where these billions of
dollars went are cared to try to get
them back
that's when you start looking you know
you know you've got a big story
and so you just keep going i mean and
everywhere i looked i found something it
was like i mean being in the oil
business everywhere you you dig a hole
you hit oil i mean every rock you turn
over something scurries out from under
it
and uh it's just a it was a wonderful
story in that sense well you even have i
mean
divorce decrees were significant things
like this yeah well you know that
the snls do not
the documents at the snl's are not
public the loan documents where the
money went the closing documents the
public can't get them reporters cannot
get them we cannot track the money we
don't have subpoena power so the things
you rely on are lawsuits and deed
records basically and so the divorce
decrees are in divorce lawsuits are very
they have a lot of good information in
them
pete let's go into the history of how
you actually came to write this book
starting with your first stories with
the houston post in the spring of 86 i
was working on stories involving
charitable foundations and hospitals
that were
not
doing enough services for the poor
and
a business reporter at the post named
greg c got an anonymous call
from a guy that we had we dealt with for
over two years and we his nickname was
dt which was you know
short for deep throat and for a long
time we didn't even know who who he was
well this guy calls up greg
and tells him he should start
investigating mainland savings and there
it's deals with a man named howard
pulver
so greg starts doing this
and we eventually found out pulver and
his partners had over 300 companies
and they were doing deals with mainland
all over houston and greg just found
himself drowning in a sea of records
there were thousands and thousands of
pages of records
in the the real property records of
harris county on these deals with
mainland so i was asked just to come
help him sort out the records
and we did that and then we went and
interviewed raymond hill the chief
executive officer of mainland savings
and hill's attitude
was was the most arrogant that i've ever
encountered in in my career as a
reporter
and basically
he accused us at one point of stumbling
in the same direction as the fbi
and
i knew i had a big story just the way he
was acting like we can't touch him
and and started really thumbing his nose
at us that i knew that there was a big
story there and and we immediately ran
into the mafia
there was a when we were trying to track
the deal with with howard pulver who
lived in kings point long island outside
new york
and his partners were all from new york
city they came down and took close to
100 million dollars out of mainland
savings left them with with promissory
notes that were worth you know probably
less than 10 million dollars
a huge rip-off and contributed greatly
to the failure of mainland savings
at the same time he was doing this
mario rindo was brokering money into
mainland in fact there was an indictment
in brooklyn by the organized crime
strike force
talking about the money mario rinda was
skimming
off of his deposits
and placing in various snls and one of
them was mainland
so we knew we had something maybe went
up to new york city and we found
rinda's partner in this was a guy named
martin schwimmer who was also laundering
money for the lucchese mafia family
okay when we went to talk to
howard pulver and the mark swimmer we
found they lived across the street from
each other in kings point new york which
is a very wealthy
suburban enclave on the north shore of
long island very exclusive
and so here we had
schwimmer
pumping maybe 100 million dollars in
deposits into mainland and the guy who
lives across the street from him taking
about a hundred million dollars out the
back door
and so we knew he had something very big
then and then we found we started
tracking rinda
and then we heard about herman k beebe
louisiana mafia associate who was
involved in all the failed texas snl's
we started tracking
bb and then we find bibi and rinda
together at so many different place
here's a new york mafia associate and a
louisiana mafia associate both at the
same places the same times across the
country
so you know we knew that there was a big
big story here were you shocked or
surprised to see that the mafia was
active in looting these snl banks in
texas or had you studied organized crime
before just on a couple of occasions
we'd run into i mean the myth is there's
no organized crime in texas and it's a
it's it's wrong it's just flat wrong
there are there are a couple of small
indigenous mafia families in texas but
no big mafia family but
texas is basically under the aegis of
the louisiana
the carlos marcelo mafia family and
there's a lot of mafia activity in in
texas i mean of course anytime you have
you know
people like the old texas oil men that
naturally like to gamble i mean the way
the mafia gets their their foot in the
door and their fingers into a community
a new committee is through gambling
i mean that's the way to do it and of
course all men
naturally love anybody likes to gamble
has got all that money
i mean they're gonna have to if you bet
big on anything illegally you're dealing
with the mafia probably where you know
it or not and if you don't pay up you're
going to find out in a hurry there's a
christian thing yeah and and that we
found that if you look at all the
the congressional crime
committees and in their studying of
course marcel you find in one case where
he was talking to a houston lawman named
josie in one case and and we find john
meakem jr
the houston oil man dealing with the
marcelos
so i mean
you find them in texas and dealing with
a lot of the big wheeler dealers and
power brokers
the story was this was running in the
houston post
but i've noticed in studying local power
structures in the media that the usually
the local
media don't take on or expose any of the
activities of local power brokers but
you were writing about mishra well i was
writing about him but none of the
stories i miss were running okay all
this
censored yeah
when we had done we spent two years
working on the mafia and then we found
out about the cia and
i spent another year working on the cia
and that's where i ran into mishra's
former son-in-law robert corson and then
all
the connections when i started looking
at mishra the connections of mishra to
the snl players
and that took me about a year to do and
in the
fall of 1989 we were ready to run with
the cia s l stories
and walter messier of course was the
center
in the center of it and and his
his story the story about him was
scheduled to lead it off
i mean because he's the glue that holds
all this together and it's very
difficult to understand
the story without walter mischer now
there may be somebody above misher
telling him what to do and i was told by
a couple of people in houston that there
is indeed
but i was never able to identify that
person if indeed that person exists but
mishear was is the key middleman
the key broker of all the deals and
without him it's very difficult to
understand these stories
the stories were scheduled to run in in
the
winter of 1989
we sent them over to the houston post
law firm fulbright and jaworski to read
for libel they sort of read all the
stories for libel
and try to give us advice
usually
they they they had the authority
although they shouldn't have
to kill stories that they thought might
get us into liable trouble well
fulbright and jaworski went through the
ceiling on mishra they immediately
reacted now we can't run this stuff and
gave a lot of bogus reasons for not
doing so
so we began in in the
in in february of 1990 to run the cia
stories but nothing on mishra we had
course and we had
a kansas city guy named farhat azeema
we had a little savings along atlanta
called peoples that was was lending
money to cia people in florida
we had silverado savings and in san
jacinto we ran all these these stories
but nothing on mission and
we ran out of stories eventually in the
in the summer of 1990. it must have been
difficult to write your story with the
main actor not being able very difficult
and and most of the national media
reacted negatively i mean
they did not pick up the story um
they said you know they it was too hard
to understand and a lot of other reasons
i think and also the houston post is to
blame for for one thing for not running
a big series they would just have one
story and wait several weeks and run
another one and wait
and i think it's just because they were
afraid of the story they were afraid you
know they just kind of want to stick
their little foot in the water and
see if it got bit off and then run
another one if it didn't
and so they were they were released
sporadically
and there was no measure in it so
a lot of the national media did not pick
up i don't know if we'd run them as a
series and had measure whether
that had any more impact it's difficult
to tell the national media really
handles the cia with kid gloves and we
can talk about that later why if you'd
like to but anyway
we'd run out of stories so i went back
to the measure stuff and i tried to get
that in again
and
the editor signed off on it
they approved it i thought i had met all
of fulbright and jaworski's objections
and they were scheduled to run
in the last of december of 1990
and then at the very last moment
fulbright zworski refused to sign off on
the stories the editors even though the
city editor
wanted to run them and and really
recommended running them over fulbright
jaworski's objections
the editor-in-chief decided
not to do it not through the mystery
stories now during this period i was
talking i was at my folks ranch
it was christmas time
i was talking to the city editor
and
the fulbright jaworski associate that
was handling the mystery stuff guy named
tom godbold
and i was talking on the phone the city
editor said godbold won't sign off on
him
and and i was i was furious and i said
his job's probably on the line i bet he
won't get made partner if he doesn't
kill these stories you know i was just
just talking i was mad
well six weeks later i'd taken leave of
absence to write work on the book and i
had lunch with the city editor and he
looked at me said guess what
bowled just got made partner
and that's albright and jaworski so
that's when i started looking for
conflicts of interest now
a year and a half earlier when godbold
was objecting to all the mystery stuff i
directly asked him do you have any does
fulbright jorowski have any conflicts of
interest with these stories and he said
not that i know of
okay when i i found
close to a dozen conflicts of interest
including the fact that fulbright
jaworski was representing mischer's
company in a wrongful death lawsuit
at the same time they were telling us we
couldn't run these stories about walter
mischer in addition they were also doing
other things for missure as well
as doing legal things for palmer
national bank this bank in washington
d.c
they had represented howard pulver's
company and an insurance deal and on and
they had laundered money
for a for the cia basically through the
md anderson foundation
and conflict after conflict i dug up on
for ranchowarski now i went to the
houston post i told them about these
conflicts
and the houston post did nothing and so
i knew that that i could not go back
back to work for the houston post if i'm
going to have to
run everything through fulbright and
swarsky who was serving as the ultimate
editors on all these stories
so was it at this time you decided to go
the book route that you'd resign from
the houston post and try to write this
up as a book well actually uh it
happened earlier during the middle of
the stories i was writing for the for
the post in the summer of 1990 simon and
schuster came to me actually approached
me
with an idea of writing a book for them
simon shuster is either the first or
second largest publishing company a
country in this
company in this country
and
very prestigious
and they flew me up to new york city and
rolled out the red carpet
and made me a very big offer
to write the book for them 100
100 000 advance which is probably bigger
than any
advance on a savings and loan book
that's been been written
and uh so we began negotiating a
contract
and i was insistent in the beginning at
the very beginning that the book be
published before the 1992 presidential
election when this is in by the way the
summer of 1990
and uh because not only because of what
i found on george bush but what i'd
found on lloyd benson and at that time
it certainly wasn't beyond the realm of
possibility that the 92 election was
going to be bush versus benson
and in fact if you recall when clinton
had all the trouble
and earlier this year
with in january february with jennifer
flowers in the draft he said that if he
dropped out he was going to throw his
support behind lloyd benson and now we
have benson being the leading candidate
for the secretary of treasury
okay so
i was pushing very hard and and uh thor
brian zworski actually modified their
standard contract
to shorten the time between acceptance
and publication between simon simon
schuster i'm sorry to shorten the time
between acceptance and publication
and i eventually signed a contract with
them and when i took a leave of absence
from the post to write the book
i submitted the book on deadline
and
i got back an editing letter a couple of
months after that
that told me that something wasn't
exactly right here because they wrote me
a four-page letter that was just full of
vague nonsense i mean it was not helpful
at all
and when i submitted the manuscript on
deadline i again put in writing
that the book had to be published before
the 1992 election
in writing
so we began the editing process
and i tried to accommodate their
suggestions and i really couldn't i made
some alternative suggestions they okayed
it i submitted a revised manuscript in
february
of this year 92
and
after they got the revised manuscript
but before they'd even read it they
really cut me off they would not return
my phone calls my faxes my letters
nothing
and so
i was fairly desperate at that time
and i knew that they had what they call
their fall list the list of all the
books they published
in the latter part of the year and i
knew that my book had to be on there to
get out before the election
and so when they wouldn't return my
phone calls or talk to me i eventually
made an appointment just to fly up to
new york city and see them
and it that it was only at that time
that that they that they returned my
phone call
and i told the editor who was alice
mayhew
who was bob woodward's editor a very
famous editor
you know that the book needed to go
before the election we needed to get
going and she said she wasn't going to
do it they were not going to do the book
before the election
and i said why not you know all this
stuff about bush the american public
needs to know
and she said quote george bush is going
to win anyway
and of course it turned out to be wrong
but even so that struck me as nonsense
what difference does that make about
getting
getting the information before the
public and what how does she know that
what's going to happen in uh it was
again in 10 months or so
why do you think simon and schuster
refused to publish the book before the
election was ready to go right well
it was basically ready and if they'd
wanted to they could have he was not i
mean simon shuster is a very big company
i mean i eventually got the book
published before the election with a
small company i mean they could have put
two editors on it and we could have done
it
they didn't
um
i don't know i mean i don't want to
speculate on their motives but there's
some interesting connections
in fact i knew this going in i knew
about the connections between simon
schuster
and george bush and the houston power
brokers oh what is that well
one of george bush's best friends and
long time business associates hugh
ledgke chairman of the board of pennzoil
is on the board of directors of simon
schuster's parent corporation paramount
communications
and hugh leakey is actually in my book
in regard to a very strange bank in
houston that he was on the board up
also
paramount communications used to be as
is the successor company to gulf and
western
the conglomerate that one of the
founding fathers is john duncan of
houston whose brother charles was
secretary of energy under the carter
administration and these people are in
investments
with people who connect to walter
mischer and and back to george bush and
so i knew this going in i just thought
it'd be poetic justice for simon shuster
to publish this book
you know
but apparently they knew about it too i
guess
pete you've been you've been dealing
with some pretty unsavory and dangerous
characters here the cia and the mafia
have you had any threats in your life or
you've been fearful of it well i'm not
that i know i'm kind of slow maybe i got
threatened and i didn't realize it but
nothing directly
i mean these people
usually leave reporters and they don't
you know threaten reporters i mean they
may try to keep the book from being
published
or they might threaten you with i mean
i've been threatened with lawsuits oh i
mean they will do that but not
physically threatened
and you know they the way they operate
is to keep people like simon schuster
from publishing the book or keep anybody
from publishing or keeping it from being
distributed
and so you know they work indirectly not
i mean if anything happened to me that
would just bring more publicity on this
and which is the last thing they want i
mean the way they're reacting to the
book is that they're really sort of kind
of hunkering down and ignoring it
and figuring that any publicity will
will vanish eventually and disappear
have you been contacted by larry king
yet or any of these no
the national media has shown no interest
in this
one exception is the village voice that
published a excellent
article on your book and on your
research by jonathan whitney who's also
an investigative reporter of some
renowned right that happened when
scientists used to told me they were not
going to publish before the election
i contacted whitney i had been in touch
with jonathan whitney because he'd
written a number of books on the same on
the mafia and the cia
and uh you know i wanted to sort of do a
reality check and send the manuscript to
whitney and ask him whether he thought
it should be published before the
election just to make sure that i wasn't
hallucinating maybe simon shuster was
right
and so i sent the manuscript to whitney
and he read it and agreed with me that
it should be published before the
election
and he was helping me you know get the
information out and and actually was was
had gone to a number of different
publications to try to do you know a
serialization of the book and eventually
the village voice did it but just barely
before the election and even though the
book was printed
four weeks before the election
uh it really didn't get out i mean it
should have been out in the summer you
know i really apologize
i did everything that i knew how and and
if so you told somebody in say may of
this year
that you could get a book published in
five months they would have laughed at
you so it was not possible well we did
it but just barely
pete let's uh talk a little bit about
the sort of final
response of your work by the
establishment by journalists
congress and then possibly the public
and how you reacted to the sort of
non-response of the sort of journalist
establishment and then the congress you
yourself was a were a reporter for the
human houston post you published these
articles about the cia and the snl's or
explosive
investigative reporting and they just
weren't picked up by the national uh
media what did this lead you to conclude
towards the press in the united states
did this change your attitude anyway
well i mean
some of the press picked up the stories
but the
the television networks and the big
three the new york times the washington
post and wall street journal never did
anything
and
i personally think the reason they
didn't was because it wasn't their story
okay and they like to do their own
investigative work and they were very
far behind it would have been impossible
for them
to do
the work it would take to do these
stories in in a manner that would you
know that would be a good job
and these these institutions had not
even done the s l stories right i mean
they had ignored basically nor done a
little bit but it was all
they were just recycling
uh the work that had basically been done
by the dallas morning news and byron
harris wfaa in dallas which was to write
about all the wheeler dealer don dixon
ed mcburney types
and that began to be sort of the pattern
of investigative reporting if you did
investigate reporting on snl
you wrote about all the wild and crazy
guys down in texas that were looting
this these snls and you didn't do what
you should have done which was follow
the money
that's a big advice you know deep throat
gave bob woodward in watergate follow
the money that's where the that's where
the story is that's where the story is
in the snl's but the reporters did not
do that
it was right about the front man the
wild and crazy guys
so these institutions did not do a very
good job on the snl's so they didn't
have the foundation
to do either the mafia or the cia
involvement
so you know if you don't do something
they're the kind of
institutions and people that just ignore
it you know it's not our story it's not
worth doing we're just going to ignore
it
you know if we didn't do it it must not
be worth anything so that's exactly what
happens now what about
congress when you first made these
revelations that the cia was involved in
robbing the cia
the savings and loan and using the money
to help support the countries and other
illegal off the book operations congress
made some noise that they were going to
do
some investigation what came out of this
well actually the the house permanent
subcommittee on intelligence which
has oversight of cia
did a preliminary investigation by their
staff
and eventually came up and said there's
nothing to this
but it's interesting there are several
interesting points to note
number one
they never did what they should have
done which was tracking the money they
relied
on the cia for all their information
and
even the cia admitted
that of the like the 20 institutions
we named
that they had dealt with
four of them
and
that they had dealt with five of the
individuals
we had named but they had done nothing
wrong
and the thing is that the staff director
of the house intelligence committee who
was overseeing the investigation a guy
named dan chiles had come from the sea
was the the chief financial officer of
the cia and had been brought over to the
intelligence
subcommittee
right before my stories came out and the
cia of course was aware i mean i had
been talking to them for months so they
knew
that my stories were going to break soon
dan childs also had been brought in 10
years earlier
in the senate
intelligence committee that had been
doing the church investigation was
exposing all the illegal domestic
activities of the cia
child had been brought in for damage
control it certainly looked like he was
being brought in for damage control and
in fact after they
released their report
saying there was nothing to this child
went back to see now he's the executive
assistant to the cia director this is
shameless it's like this guy pogar who
was put in charge of investigating iran
contra who is another
lifetime cia operative station chief of
about six different places as you point
out in your
book so basically congress didn't do
anything no they covered it up the press
really didn't do anything and now the
clinton administration faces as much as
a 500 billion dollar price tag for the
cia
scandal so what can the government
finally do
about this congress and the justice
department can track the money that's
all they have to do and if there was
fraud involved they can get it back
and they haven't done this i mean
everybody's acting like it's a foregone
conclusion that we've lost 500 billion
dollars you know okay taxpayers take the
hit and go on it's not true
the justice department is very capable
of tracking this money they can track
drug money it starts out as cash in the
united states goes offshore and comes
back surely they can track snl money
that's always a paper or wire transfer
it's easy to track if you've got
subpoena power congress could do it but
they're not doing it and i don't know
whether clinton is going to make the
justice department do this or not
you know where it's going to be
interesting who the new attorney general
is going to be and whether they're going
to go out i mean i don't see any
indication of clinton's part that he has
any interest
in in kicking this sleeping dog
and i think he just wants to let it lie
and not mess with it because his party
is just as involved as the as
republicans
and so i don't see
that's going to have to take just be
mass revoked by the american people and
the american people don't have the
information
so what is the responsibility of the
press and the citizens
to do something about this snl scandal
well the press has got to do the
reporting and the citizens have to do
the complaining
you're watching alternative views
we turn now to some news stories
from the alternative press
world press review has some
the stories some opinions of various
newspapers are around the world most of
the quotes are
oh
not all that significant but there are a
couple of them that i thought you might
be interested in one from munich
independent newspaper says it's
difficult to discern a program or policy
in the new president's persona he
succeeded in pleasing everyone
and antagonizing
no one
and it was a very perfect marketing
strategy so their conclusion was that
clinton was not elected
bush was summarily fired
and in tehran
they said that our experience with the
usa during the past half century has
left us with no illusions about either
republicans or democrats
a desire for hegemony is so deep rooted
in the psyche of the american political
establishment
that the new president even though he's
a democrat
has no choice but to tread the path of
norm
in traditional usa foreign policy
one of bill clinton's chief campaign
pledges was to limit the influence of
lobbyists in washington d.c
well the new york times news service
reports that his transition team has
extensive industry and
ties and ties to foreign countries for
instance vernon jordan the transition
chairman earns at least 442 000 a year
from in fees from sitting on the boards
of eleven corporate giants including
union carbide american express xerox and
the debt laden rjr nabisco
jordan also holds almost a million
dollars worth of stock in these
companies
in his law firm aiken gunpower feld
represents at least seven of these
corporations as well and is a senior
partner he shares in the law firm's park
profits
the transition director working right
under jordan warren christopher is the
senior partner in one of the nation's
largest law firms omelvani and myers
whose clients include mitsui sumitomo
trust and banking japan airlines and
hyundai
and during the campaign clinton made a
point of criticizing lobbyists who work
for foreign interests but the japanese
interests at least are well represented
in his uh transition team as well
christopher earned at least 73 thousand
dollars last year from sitting on the
boards of lockheed corporation and
southern california edison and his firm
also represents both corporations so you
can imagine what sort of feelings this
person is going to have about
regulating utilities and also military
cutbacks
also uh mickey cantor another board
member on the transition team is a
member of mannet phelps phillips and
cantor which has done works for the
government done work for the governments
of cyprus and jamaica and for a wide
array of
for-profit health care corporations real
estate and transportation firms
he also does lobbying for japan's nec
corporation the cable television
industry and a number of big oil
companies
he also
on the side conducted a policy brief
briefing for a number of his clients and
potential clients including general
electric
samuel berger another member the
transition team's foreign policy
director
also has for years presided over an
international trade firm a prac the
international trade practice at hogan
and hartson a law firm whose clients
have included poland czechoslovakia the
bahamas ontario japan again and the
trading arm of china
as well as the toshiba corporation of
japan and when toshiba got in trouble
with the us government for exporting a
sensitive technology
to the soviet the former soviet union
berger was there in washington helping
to defend toshiba's interests
as ralph nader put it cesar chavez isn't
getting any calls and there have been
widespread complaints from the coalition
that elected clinton which includes many
civil rights leaders
people working for migrant farmers
people working for other minority rights
that people from these
institutions just haven't been called
upon clinton's gone for the traditional
lobbyists and lawyers who have always
been sitting inside the beltway
dictating what's done to the congressman
i think it's very significant
that what was that from the new york
times washington post new york times
news service
right see they're not going to point out
other connections and interconnections
with clinton and the staff that he's
putting together
for instance
i look at the sociology of leadership
what organizations do these people come
from
and who are the other people that they
associate with well bill clinton was a
member of the bilderberger said secret
organization
as well as the council on foreign
relations
vernon jordan is a member of the council
on foreign relations and the trilateral
commission warren christopher is a
member of all three of those elite
organizations uh senator evans little
henry cisneros is a member of the cfr
and of course lloyd benson
the
you they say you're going to be our new
secretary of treasure
he
has
attended bilderberg meetings uh recently
as well so the people that clinton has
in his
transition team are people from this
very small
group of elite organizations and very
few people are members of these
organizations council foreign relations
only has about 15 to 1700
but the number of people in government
from these organizations is huge
compared to their size so we're seeing
the same type of thing that we did
before in the
in actually in the in the bush and
reagan years they came from these
organizations well the carter people and
the carter so it's just basically carter
carter revisited except clinton is more
conservative than carter
and clinton came from the
the
democratic leadership council which was
a rebellion against the liberal hegemony
of the democrats and i saw a statistic
where it said that the
congress people who also
support the democratic leadership
council they voted with the reagan bush
years they voted for reagan and bush 80
to 90 percent of the time so it's
questionable as how much change
bill clinton wants or how much he can
achieve even if he wants it
so this i think is a major indication
that at least when it comes to economics
it's going to be business as usual with
the clinton administration my guess is
that clinton's going to continue the
conservative policies of the previous
decade in the area of economics and
foreign policy and he'll have a much
more liberal agenda on social issues
world press review has a couple of
articles about the mafia which are
really quite disturbing
says that the mafia
like the rest of the economy in the 80s
has gone global global
and has forged alliances wherever it's
needed to
killed wherever it's needed to
and is sponsoring indigenous crime
syndicates under its control in a lot of
countries where
they weren't operating before
particularly say in eastern europe
it has
managed to come to grips and work out
relationships with the turkish heroin
bosses the columbia drug cartels so
internationally it's
stronger than it ever has been and even
you know you hear references here and
there to the russian mafia
taking over so much of what is happening
in the chaos in
in russia right now
well that mafia is actually
connected with the italian sicilian
mafia
things have changed a bit though
and that
the mafia still kills in italy they've
seen that
however they've kind of
gone along with the colombian style of
killing now they used instead of just uh
very clean assassinations with their
rifles or so
there's there were some machine guns
they're doing it now with car bombs
which actually kills some a lot of
civilians as well
as an indication
of the strength and internationalization
of the mafia on saint valentine's day
appropriately enough in 1989 there is a
meeting in nice of members of the
international
consortium of
illegals
the sicilian mafia
which is the octopus the giant mafia
they also
with representatives of the colombian
and venezuelan cartels
well they all got together so that they
could divide up the world's spoils
so they wouldn't have competition with
each other they wouldn't be trampling on
each other or they wouldn't have to be
killing each other
cartelization of
crime around the world
and what's happening in italy there have
been some
well-publicized assassinations recently
and the people have
had a lot of outcry against the mafia
but this has been going on for some time
there will be assassinations people come
up in arms there will be investigations
and the government say well we're going
to do something about it but then
nothing ever gets done it's business as
usual and that is because according to
world press review articles the
establishment in italy is right in bed
and has a very cozy working relationship
with the mafia and so they're not doing
anything about it so they're becoming
stronger and stronger all around the
world it's ironic this parallel
development with international capital
and the mafia keeps lockstep right along
with it
well according to the new york times a
rising cost of modernity is depression
if the 20th century ushered in the age
of anxiety its exit according to the
times is witnessing the dawn of the age
of melancholy the first international
study of major depression reveals a
steady rise in the disorder worldwide
the nation's as diverse as the united
states taiwan lebanon and new zealand in
these countries in each generation the
possibility of getting serious
depression not just sadness but a
paralyzing listlessness dejection
self-depreciation and overwhelming sense
of hopelessness that these days is three
times likelier that you're going to get
this depression it's going to set in
than your grandparents there's been a
lot of speculation of why melancholy is
on the rise some speculate the loss and
a belief of god takes away a buffer
against life's setbacks others say the
distress created in women by the spread
of unattainable ideals of female beauty
is a cause whereas others say that it's
physiological it has to do more with
exposure to
toxic substances and there's been a big
debate over why younger americans also
in recent years have had a much much
higher
case of melancholy than the former
generation recent studies in journals in
the united states indicate that there's
a
much much higher proportion of people
that are getting melancholy these days
and it's become a modern epidemic
i have a couple of short articles here
on poland one from the world press
review of let's see
where does that december 1992
and the other from dollars and cents and
where's that from this also december
1992.
the
world press review says that
the
polish government foresees five more
years of recession
before things start becoming a little
bit better for the people in poland
and it seems that even that five years
taking of lead long was a compromise
between the reformists and the
people who want to go a little bit
slower and
ease the pain
but
according to dollars and cents
it's ironic that the people who are
supposedly
voicing this on the people all this pain
are the people who actually used to come
from the labor ranks
remember liquelensa was the leader of
the labor union solidarity now the
in the summer of 92 group of unions that
have spearheaded solidarity are now
going out on wildcat strikes against
solidarity and the uh walesa valencia
leadership
but there's a very interesting
quote by the prime minister
who
when some the workers started striking
she sent out dismissal notices to them
they just kick them out and so the
leaders of the strike immediately scale
back their wage demands
well the woman who was the prime
minister
came from a satellite party of the
communists originally back in 1984
and she was expelled from the party
for voting against taking away
solidarity's legal status but she's
changed her mind now here's what she
says about the workers
for 40 years
the workers were treated as the most
important class
on which the whole system of the state
stood
and it's very bitter for them to
understand that the new conditions
require them to step down
to a very
low
status
and that brings us to the end of this
alternative views
frequently hear from viewers who request
a list of news publications which we use
on alternative views and also a reading
list for us power structure in the mass
media
if you would like to have these send a
stamped self-addressed envelope
to the alternative information network
p o box 7279
austin texas 787 13 you must send a
self-addressed stamped envelope
we'd like to extend our thanks to a lot
of people who helped make the program
possible particularly pete brewton who
wrote the incredible book the mafia the
cia and george bush
our crew for the interview consisted of
brian lynch ashley blake mary mcdonald
and dana craven
for our news section eric eubank was on
camera kevin l west did the audio
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
p.o box 7279
austin texas
787-13
goodbye
you